gérard filoche vient de nous rejoindre
ancien inspecteur du travail et membre
de la gauche démocratique et social et
membre de la cgt bonsoir merci d'être
sur ce plateau à vos côtés toujours
présents sur ce plateau philippe de
voeux du collectif europe noir et gilet
jaune
gérard filoche il ya donc une heure le
premier ministre s'est exprimé il
déclenche le 49-3 votre première
réaction
comme des millions de français je suis
indigné ça s'apparente à un coup d'état
je veux dire en même temps c'est un coup
de faiblesse
les deux d'une part parce que c'est
vraiment un gouvernement violent
méprisant pour les millions de
manifestants qui a eu pour contre 70% de
la population française qui exige le
retrait de cette caste des retraites
c'est méprisant sur ses parts et
d'autres quel autre beau dire je me
demande comment pouvoir peut arriver est
aussi aveugle et violent à la fois
comment il peut être ce s'estimer au
dessus avec une mission contre une
personne lui a demandé cette réforme des
retraites
personne ne voulait de ça et il va
baisser de 25% les retraites de tous les
français aujourd'hui dans un pays qui
n'a jamais été aussi riche de son
histoire et où il faut plutôt parler de
partage des richesses qu restrictions et
austérité
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup de force
dans le temps c'est la faiblesse parce
que qu'est ce que ça doit être indiquée
entre edouard philippe et macron
qu'est-ce que ça indique entre sa la
direction de la cfdt
où est la commission de financement que
sont devenus leurs 113 milliards
annoncés plat maintenant on va voir quoi
29 ordonnance
s'ils sont pas arrêtés par une motion de
censure 29 ordonnance qu ils vont écrire
comme ils volent dans les semaines qui
viennent avec même pas on verra ce que
le sénat vote que va t'il faire en
rajouter donc c'est il ya des
contradictions partout et ses
contradictions
j'espère que la réaction populaire
justement millions de salariés va les
mettre à jour
justement de réaction populaire donc
vous êtes nombre de la cgt à vos côtés
philippe de veules qui est
une personnalité de gilet jaune est-ce
qu' il peut y avoir une convergence des
luttes est ce que
les deux 2e jean gilet jaune isation des
syndicats et une syndicalisation des
gilet jaune
la convergence aller établi c'est pas
une confiance et une fusion on a tous
les mêmes intérêts aujourd'hui qu'on
soit 1 euro au milieu au bas du salariat
c'est le salariat 30 millions de
salariés qui sont attaqués parce que
c'est 30 millions de retraités qui sont
concernés et gilet jaune syndicats tous
devraient réagir normalement dans la rue
la grève revient à l'ordre du jour et
puis la manifestation devant l'assemblée
nationale
une manifestation centrale pourquoi pas
nationale à paris philippe de veulent
à cela s'ajoute évidemment salariés les
professions libérales les avocats les
médecins les infirmières enfin les
toutes les professions qui étaient
jusqu'à présent considérés comme des
professions de notables et qui joue
aussi un rôle important dans les
institutions par classe moyenne oui la
classe moyenne la classe moyenne la
classe moyenne supérieure si vous voulez
et c'est à dire que avec ce régime on
arrive à une paupérisation je dire les
avocats avec cette réforme qui va passer
ont beaucoup 30% des cabinets vont
fermer beaucoup de deux confrères sont
obligés de teint de fermer leur cabinet
parce qu'ils ne pourront pas payer les
charges qui leur seront imposées
un petit mot de politique politicienne
vous connaissez bien la politique gérard
filoche le projet de loi sera considéré
comme adopté sauf si une motion de
censure déposée dans les 24 heures par
l'opposition par l'opposition est votée
à l'assemblée nationale parce que tester
ces olim a dit jean luc mélenchon et
fabien roussel
je suppose qu'ils sont déjà au téléphone
pour être cette motion en commun parce
que là s'il n'y a pas d'unité de la
gauche je sais plus aubin d'habitude
jean luc mélenchon dit que dans 90% des
cas les groupes à l'assemblée nationale
vote ensemble des groupes de gauche
voilà c'est le moment de le prouver et
en plus il y aura des conséquences parce
que dans l'assemblée nationale
comment dirais je dis pas que ça se
désactive en face ça va pas bien quoi le
coup d'état de
de d'edouard philippe il est aussi con
sa propre majorité combien 22 députés de
die dans marges qui sont partis les
autres sa future action contre 803 ce en
dépit d'un arrêt technique en marche à
ses 280 je prends pas la tête et
politicienne mais eux c'est des
politiciens assez nul c'est compris
qu'ils doivent philippe doit s'exprimer
ce soir dans le journal télévisé de tf1
à 20 heures qu'est ce que vous attendez
d'eux
de son allocution film de vol j'attends
pas parce qu'il a dit il a dit qu'il
s'exprimait pour mettre fin à cet
épisode de non débat
en gros c'est pour mettre fin à
l'obstruction parlement de tous les noms
d'oiseaux fait par des députés de la
république en marche
donc il faut arrêter cette comédie ce
cinéma vont évidemment monsieur doit
finit pas un flegme quiconque on peut
féliciter mais en fin de compte je crois
qu'il est dogmatique dans dans ses
réformes mais si on veut parler de
politique politicienne évidemment il ya
le la gauche mais je suis sûr qu'il ya
aussi des des ralliements de la droite
chez shell l air ou ou rn à mon avis
qu'ils iront dans le l'objectif de la
motion censure mais malheureusement elle
pourra pas elle pourrait elle pourra pas
arriver à terme parce qu'ils sont 300 et
ils ont la majorité donc cette motion de
censure sera évidemment balayé mais
évidemment il faut à tout prix la mettre
en marche
ils ont 24 heures justement qu'est ce
qui va se passer lors de ses prochaines
heures il va y avoir les fameuses 24
heures et lors de
ces prochains jours même j'ai envie de
dire ce qu'il faut s'attendre un regain
de mobilisation dans la rue gérard
filoche jeudi dernier le côté d un autre
côté il ya des confinement aussi duo
coronavirus par exemple un rassemblement
de plus de cinq mille personnes
le fait de me dire attention ne
manifestaient pas plus de 5,8 vous êtes
vous quand les lieux confinés dans les
lieux pendant des millions d'années dans
les lieux partenaires ont pas besoin
excusez mon lacet c'est peut-être pas un
hasard
j'ai tellement de moi aussi un peu
d'hostilité tête contre ce pouvoir si en
douce il essaie de le faire pendant une
période comme celle ci c'est scandaleux
c'est ce que veut dire en même temps
dénoncé les dix personnages et la
population oui et en même temps on fait
contre la population et coup de force
pour lui prendre sa retraite
et évidemment les chaussons vont pas
empêcher les mobilisations les
organisations syndicales ont dit que
s'il y avait 1 49 3 il y aurait un
rendez-vous aussi tôt à l'assemblée
nationale et je pense que c'est ce qui
est à l'ordre du jour je ne suis pas
responsable syndical c'est pas moi qui
donne des consignes s'il était je dirais
tous tout le monde tout de suite dans la
rue à devant l'assemblée nationale
et en plus je préparais des ripostes au
niveau national pour paralyser
l'application de cette politique des
lois philippe et ils sont si quand même
ce pouvoir qui minoritaire c'est pas
nous sonné majorité son pays derniers
mois il nous reste une trentaine de ce
volet social pour cent des français sont
contre cette réforme et je pense que la
meilleure manière de faire cette motion
censure qu'elle arrive ces deux motions
de censure dans la rue c'est hier que ce
soit là la souveraineté populaire qui
manifestent et je crois qu'on n'y
arrivera combien même il ya d'une crise
très grave à laquelle on doit faire face
sur le sort de cette crise du coroner à
virus c'est le mot de la fin merci
philippe de veules et gérard filoche
d'être intervenu pour commenter donc
cette actualité
une